[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covile 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi anciens ministres et
directeurs généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous propose de revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui la deuxième partie
de celle d'agnès busan l'ancien ministre
de la santé était très attendu sur sa
gestion des masques au début de
l'épidémie mais aussi sur ses
déclarations dans la presse au lendemain
du premier tour des municipales où elle
compare ces élections à une mascarade
écoutez agnès buzyn madame la ministre
également je voulais dire je vous
remercie pour la sincérité et c'est bien
d'avoir appelé le chaînage des dates il
ya une chose que je voudrais comprendre
vous n'êtes dire à l'instant 2018 avec
mon collègue américain on voit bien que
le risque infectieux est un risque
majeur
jérôme salle mon aide emmanuel macron
est pris dans la république en lui
faisant des notes c'est votre dgs vous
le voyez sans arrêt et je ne vois pas
comment l'état ne s'est pas mieux
préparé je parle pas de poste
déclaration d'épidémique comment en
amont sur toutes ses dépendances que
nous avons sur l'ensemble des matériels
de protection
on n'est pas tes changer le paradigme
français ce d'autant plus quelque chose
que je ne comprends pas de la part des
agences santé publique france nous
faisons le deux jours on a envoyé des
notes au cabinet à la ministre au dgs et
on n'a pas eu de retour
et franchement ce problème de la
doctrine on doit le comprendre parce que
il est indispensable que l'on sache
pourquoi on sait pas mieux préparé c'est
une alerte qui avait été lancé au
président et il semble pas qu'on soit
puis préparer la seconde chose sur les
tests vous avez dit manat ministre fort
justement que c'est le dise que le
séquençage du virus et trouver le 17 les
chercheurs français à lyon pasteur honte
su mettre au point un test qui
fonctionnait et vous le savez
formidablement bien parce que vous avez
visité les laboratoires p 3 je parle
même pas des p2p un os des labos de
ville la déclinaison territoriale a été
très longue et au début on cherchait les
écouvillon c'est la dgs qui cherchait
découvrions pour faire les prélèvements
donc simplement ce que vous dire ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment qu'on a un
problème d'organisation
agence et qu' on doit préparer l'avenir
préparer une nouvelle pandémie
et cette préparation de nouvelles
pandémies alain pose franchement des
modifications d'organisation de ces
agences et surtout de l'autorité de la
déclinaison que le ministre peut avoir
dans les décisions qu'il prend parce que
sinon demain peut se répéter ce qu'ils
ont envie en train de vivre aujourd'hui
et je pense c'est gravissime en passion
tranquillement
merci monsieur triaud vigier peut-être
reprendre ce que vous dites concernant
la note de santé publique france à la
suite de l'audition de monsieur
bourdillon j'ai fait sortir cette
semaine de mai archi de la totalité des
courriers des notes qui ont été envoyées
ainsi qu'à mon cabinet ni rien voilà je
n'ai pas d'information les courriers que
j'ai retrouvées dans des archives qui
m'ont été fournies cette semaine
concerne les âges et les i transverse du
monde supérieur puisqu'il y avait eu ces
cas groupés voilà sondés sont des
courriers sur le plan priorité
prévention nous avons toujours mis un
accent sur la prévention s'avère être le
dgs c'était quelque chose qui me tient
extrêmement un coeur et en tant que
ministre j'ai toujours agi en faveur de
la prévention la vaccination le tabac le
plan priorité prévention j'avais même
acte et à la demande des députés qu'il y
ait dans les faits c'est sur un chapitre
dédié au financement de la prévention
c'est vraiment un sujet majeur donc il
n'ya pas de remontée de santé publique
france vers le ministre là dessus j'ai
regardé mon dossier ministre en arrivant
au ministère qui est le dossier qui
préparait sur tout
les alertes et les risques et tout ce
que je dois avoir un ministre en tête
il n'y a pas de chapitre dédié à cela
donc je n'ai pas dallaire particulière
pour moi il ya une agence en charge ces
l'eprus qui a intégré santé publie franc
je connais l'eprus parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avec elle notamment
lorsque j'étais dans d'autres agences
sanitaires
pour moi il ya une agence qui fonctionne
et en charge je n'ai pas à mettre en
doute une agence qui a été fait pour ça
c'est sa mission elle ne fait que ça
alors après il ya une intégration dans
une autre agence mais en réalité cette
agence là elle fait l'objet d'un code
pour lequel je vérifie que des
instructions ont été données les
orientations ont été données notamment
en termes de gestion des stocks
après vous me dites est ce qu'il n'ya
pas eu une lenteur je pense que il va
falloir regarder point par point c'est
l'objet de cette mission
ou est ce qu'on aurait pu faire plus
vite sur la déclinaison des tests dans
les hôpitaux
il a fallu une quinzaine de jours pour
que entre le moment où le test est mis
en place à pasteur et le moment où ça
arrive dans tous les chu
le test se soit approprié par les
différents laboratoires des hôpitaux en
charge de réceptionner les malades on
est je le rappelle quand même on est en
phase 1/2 d'épidémie donc ya pas de
malades sur le territoire jusqu'au 24
janvier
donc voilà le moment où je déploie
d'état c'est vraiment pour faire une
détection précoce un dépistage de
malades qui arrivent avec le 15 on n'est
pas du tout dans une phase de
circulation du virus de test à grande
échelle etc
je suis dans la détection de potentiels
mala pour circonscrire des clusters et
ça fonctionne force est de constater que
ça fonctionne puisque le cluster des
contamines-montjoie est parfaitement
identifié on est capable de tester les
200 enfants les familles les contacts
dans le chalet
d'isoler de mettre en quarantaine ces
gens là sont testés de la même façon
quand je fait rapatrier les français de
one arrive à paris le 30 et le 31
janvier ils sont tous testés à leur
arrivée le lendemain ils sont tous
testés à marseille il ya 200 français
qui arrive le ca nice ont testé il ya
280 personnes qui arrivent de nouveau
dans un vol le dimanche à
aix-en-provence qu'on met en quarantaine
avec des gens de toutes les nationalités
ils sont tous tester donc les protocoles
sont mis en place pour tester des gens
alors moi je pars avant la diffusion du
virus dans avant la circulation du virus
dans la population générale
à une période où les tests sont dans les
hôpitaux on est on est dans une doctrine
d'identification des cas compact après
sur l'organisation des agences je pense
que nous avons tous la d envie de re
questionner cette organisation à l'issue
de ce que nous avons vivre vécu jeu je
pense qu'il ya eu effectivement en
termes de contrôle des stocks des
interrogations d'apprendre que très
grandes quantités de produits sont
périmés en octobre 2018 et qu'il faut
reconstituer très grandes quantités de
stocks d'état et je n'ai pas envie de
les préciser
nécessite de rang questionner commence à
fonctionner
merci caroline fiat france a soumises
merci madame la présidente
au début de vos fonctions au ministère
de la santé je vous avertis de la
situation dramatique dans nos ehpad
faute de moyens humains et matériels la
maltraitance institutionnelle si
généralise avec son autre souffrance
souffrance des soignants sous-effectif
et souffrances des résidents qui ne
peuvent bénéficier de soins élémentaires
à l'époque vous me répondiez ceci la
france n'a pas des moyens de mettre fin
à la maltraitance institutionnelle dans
nos ehpad
après qu'il y ait eu dix mille morts
dans les établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux du fait notamment du
manque de personnel médical et du manque
de matériel d'oxygène et d'oxygénation
pourriez vous réitérer ses propos
aujourd'hui en trois ans vous n'aviez
rien fait pour nos personnes âgées
résidant d'institutions sinon perdre du
temps à demander de nouveau rapport sur
le sujet à la veille de l'épidémie de
kobe 19 je reprends vos propres vos
propres propos vous saviez que la vague
de tsunami était devant nous plus tard
vous affirmiez même avoir pris la mesure
du danger dès le 20 décembre
vous aviez donc conscience du péril et
de l'hécatombe qui risquait d'arriver
dans nos ehpad
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas mis en place un
protocole sanitaire dans les
établissements pour personnes âgées
alors que les représentants du grand âge
12 ans réclamés 1
par ailleurs avant d'abandonner votre
ministère le 16 février dernier pour
vous lancer d'un campagne des
municipales
avez vous consulté vos services pour
savoir s'il y aurait des équipements de
protection individuelle en nombre
suffisant pour les soignants à plusieurs
reprises nous vous avons alerté sur les
fermetures de lits dont ceux de
ranimation la france en comptait cinq
fois moins que l'allemagne en début de
la crise
regrettez vous d'être restée sourde à
nos cris d' alerte face à ces fermetures
de lits car on ne sait jamais de quoi
demain est fait et enfin je vous ai
entendu tout à leur parler des commandes
dès fin janvier des deux pays
des équipements de protection
individuelle que pensez vous que face au
fait que au 30 juin au 30 juin c'est à
dire aujourd'hui les personnels de soins
c'est-à-dire dans les établissements de
dans les pare d'un établissement
hospitalier mais aussi des
établissements médico sociaux
on travaille encore en mode dégradé sur
blues en sacs poubelles pénurie de gand
où sont passés les commandes que vous
avez fait avec réactivité selon vos
propres mots fin janvier qui ne sont
toujours pas là au 30 juin
merci madame la députée peut-être peut
revenir la situation des ehpad les ehpad
ont toujours été considérés comme tous
les établissements de santé par le
ministère je reviens quand même sur la
contraction du temps que vous avez fait
donc l'alerté est passée le 1er janvier
même si moi même j'avais été alerté cinq
jours avant mais la première alerte
officiel c'est même pas une alerte une
notification est en fait nous apprenons
assez tardivement je peux pas vous dire
la date si les parents tête mais que les
patients les plus touchées les plus
graves sont les personnes les plus âgées
et les comorbidités c'est une
information que nous donnent les chinois
dans le courant du mois de janvier le
jour où il ya 29 40 chine notifiée par
le ms on ne sait pas que ça va toucher
plus les enfants ou les adultes ou les
diabétiques ou les personnes âgées on le
sait pas il ya 29 cas y'a pas
d'information donc c'est au fur et à
mesure que progresse le niveau
d'information donnée par les autorités
chinoises puisque nous dépendons 2 que
progressivement
ça file un peu la perception de la
maladie sur la contagiosité sur le fait
que les gens sont contagieux avant
d'être malade sur le fait que les
patients diabétiques sont plus touchés
que les autres sur le fait que en fait
la mortalité est plus importante chez
les gens j'aime bien je vais vous
redonner la cinétique de mortalité parce
qu'elle est quand même importante pour
se rendre compte que ça touche les gens
âgés il faut qu'ils aient des morts en
réalité le premier mort en chine
il est le 11 janvier le 21 janvier quand
je fais ma conférence de presse il ya
six morts en chine six morts c'est pas
là dessus qu'on sait que ça touche
principalement des gens diabétiques ou
les gens âgés ya six morts donc en
réalité
l'information que des gens les plus âgés
vont être particulièrement plus touché
par la maladie
on la fin janvier quand il ya un nombre
de personnes malades gravement est mort
suffisamment important et donc des les
réunions de toute façon dès les réunions
fait on interservices la première
réunion inter services qui est faite par
le directeur général de la santé elle
date pardon devraient elles datent du
musée mois
du 14 janvier
la 14 janvier donc 14 janvier il ya eu
deux trois morts on va être sur deux
trois morts 14 janvier il ya une
cinquantaine de cas en chine on est à 50
cas en chine dakar 14 janvier ont fait
une réunion inter services et m'ont
sensibilisé par un envoi du ministère
les établissements hospitaliers médicaux
sociaux les professionnels de santé
libéraux à la situation et aux
recommandations sanitaires dans toutes
les réunions qui ont été organisées à la
dgs sont présents la dg os donc en
charge des établissements de santé et la
dgcs en charge des établissements
médico-sociaux et sociaux donc en
réalité il n'ya pas une réunion au
ministère où on ne considère pas la
totalité des établissements de la même
façon et d'ailleurs quand je fais mes
commandes
je prends ma date fusée mans du 7
février
je dis bien que ses commandes donc qui
partent pour constituer un stock d'état
qui n'existe pas et que l'état n'est pas
censé avoir donc je prends la décision
d'un stock d'état et on le reconstitue
le 7 février
et je dis bien que ses stocks d'état
doit être délivrée aux établissements de
santé aux ehpad pour un mois de soldes
amorce voilà la commande
alors après vous me dire que ça n'arrive
pas oui ça n'arrive pas mais ça on le
sait après c'est que en fait les
produits viennent de chine et que la
chine est l'ami des 100 millions de
personnes confinées et que les usines se
sont arrêté de tourner surtout il garde
tout pour eux donc on est dit et je
comprends et je l' ai vécu moi-même je
les ai vécus comme soignante quand je
suis allé travailler
il y avait des difficultés à avoir du
matériel
je le sais
il avait des difficultés à avoir des
masques ffp2 on faisait attention était
sur blues savez vous que nous avons
appris par la suite que la matière de
première de surblouse à les fabriquer un
one la matière première pour le monde
entier
elle est fabriquée à one one ferme le 22
janvier il ya six décès comment voulez
vous commandez dès sur blues quand il ya
50 cas et 6 décès à one et que vous
venez d'apprendre qu'il ya une
transmission interhumaine et que
peut-être ça va devenir une épidémie moi
je veux bien qu'on contracte le temps
parce qu'on est tous ce parce qu'on a
vécu des choses terribles mais la
réalité c'est au moment où elle est
fermée
le 22 janvier on apprend le même jour
par le ms de la contamination
interhumaine un risque épidémique
il ya une cinquantaine de cas et il ya
six morts et les pays de l'entièreté des
pays du monde a été soumis à la même
difficulté ensuite sur les ehpad
donc je le dis l'organisation de crise
telle qu'elle est faite au ministère au
centre de crise fait qu'il ya toujours
des représentants et la dgcs donc ne
faisait pas son traité en permanence
avec le risque des établissements
vous le savez nous avons fait un énorme
travail préparatoire pour préparer une
loi quand âge je suis heureuse qu'elle
se met en place avec olivier ferrand qui
vient de créer le cinquième risque de la
sécurité sociale c'était mon projet vous
le savez quand je suis parti du
ministère il est concrétisé cette fois
ci on est tous évidemment conscients de
la nécessité de mettre plus d'argent
pour le grand page d'autonomie dans les
années qui viennent
enfin vous me parlez des lits de
réanimation
alors d'abord les lits de réanimation ne
sont pas comptés de la même façon en
allemagne et en france
en france l'hydre animations correspond
à des critères très stricts notamment en
termes de matériel
et de nombre de personnel dédié donc il
ya une définition stricte d'un livre et
animations tout le reste qui peut faire
de la réanimation s'appelle soin
intensif et c'est pas pour ça que dans
les soins à temps si vous n'avez pas du
matériel et des personnels a donc mais
en réalité en allemagne il compte dans
un même groupe d'élite soins intensifs
et des livres et animations donc moi je
ne je n'ai pas de la notion du nombre de
lits je ne sais pas y répondre mais je
pense que quand on comparera le système
de soins allemand le système de soins
français
il faut prendre en compte ce que les
allemands appellent réanimation est ce
que nous appelons réanimation et soins
intensifs parce que sinon nous
comparerons des choses qui n'ont rien à
voir ensuite sur la fermeture de lits
j'avais annoncé vous le savez madame la
députée lors du plan sur les urgences et
sur l'aval des urgences un changement
volontariste de réflexion sur la
doctrine pour ré ouvrir des lits de
médecine en aval des urgences donc
c'était une annonce qui avait été fait
dans le plan urgence de septembre 2019
avec la volonté très nette de réouvrir
des ligues ce que nous avons fait
d'ailleurs avec le plan urgence d'avoir
mis des moyens pourrait ouvrir des lits
pour les urgences en aval et j'avais
même demandé à la même période qu'on
revoie la doctrine du co perd molko
permo c'est le comité interne au
ministère et à bercy qui évaluent les
plans des nouveaux hôpitaux
j'avais demandé en septembre 2019 qu'ils
soient revus pour prévoir des hôpitaux
que j'appelais élastique c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas une doctrine strict du
nom de li mais une doctrine qui
permettent à tout moment en raison d'un
attentat d'un événement environnemental
ou d'un d'une épidémie qu'on soit en
permanence en capacité d'augmenter le
nombre de lits donc ça c'était la
demande que j'avais faite en septembre
2019 et qui voilà qui était pour moi une
évidence pour les années à venir avec
les canicules avec les reee les risques
d'attentât avec les épidémies on ne
répare pas entre guillemets en
maintenant deux ans
des hôpitaux qui ont été construits dans
les années 70 sous 80 je dirais que ça
se prend ça ce programme sur des
dizaines d'années
et donc voilà le contexte était celui
que j'ai trouvé en arrivant mais moi
même j'ai ré augmenter le budget des
hôpitaux je suis la première ministre à
l'avoir fait depuis 10 ans grâce
d'ailleurs au plfss qui a été votée ici
on était sur une autre dynamique
depuis que je suis arrivée qui était une
dynamique d'augmentation des moyens et
d'augmentation de nouveaux délits que
j'avais annoncé en septembre 2019
lors de l'annoncé du plan urgence merci
pierre dharréville pour le groupe gdr
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous écoute en essayant de
comprendre effectivement les processus
qui ont été à l'oeuvre
je te dire sur le sujet vous venez
d'évoquer vous savez que nous avons une
divergence et la crise de l'hôpital pour
nous était déjà patente et donc ça nous
a pas aidé à affronter la crise qui est
qui est survenu le 26 septembre 2018
donc monsieur bourdillon adresse une
lettre au directeur général de la santé
sur les stocks
moi ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
en réalité dans le mécanisme sait
comment se fait-il que ça ne provoque
pas dans l'administration d'un ministère
une réaction plus forte c'est à dire que
elle est quand même assez alarmante la
note de monsieur de monsieur bourdillon
d'autant qu' il nous a dit dans son
audition je le cite si l'agencé un
certain degré d'autonomie
elle est strictement opérateurs de
l'état pour ce qui est des stocks
stratégiques c'est-à-dire qu'elle
travaille sur commande des instructions
du ministère de la santé pour acquérir
pour stocker ou pour distribuer des
stocks stratégiques ainsi l' agence
reçoit chaque année une instruction
écrite qui fixe les acquisitions et
destruction d'équipements qui doit être
réactualisé en fonction du contexte un
tableau de l'état des stocks est mise à
jour régulièrement le ministère de la
santé oms dispose le jeu site l'audition
de françois bourdillon donc comment
expliquer finalement tout ça et comment
expliquer au regard de cette réalité qui
l'a décrite la faiblesse aussi des
moyens qui sont qui sont mis en face
pour faire face à cette à cette réalité
deuxième deuxième élément dont vous avez
évoquées y aurait beaucoup de choses à
discuter je vais passer vite mais la
nécessité de production locale une usine
a fermé de masques en 2018 dans les
côtes d'armor
monsieur bourdillon nous a dit avoir été
convoqué pour avoir critiqué un peu les
compressions de dépenses notamment sur
les effectifs de l'agent c'est ce que
vous le vous le confirmez est-ce que
c'était vous d'ailleurs je n'en sais
rien voilà mais on a le sentiment qu'il
ya des tensions fortes et vous semblait
d'ailleurs très critique avec la gestion
qui a été celle de santé publique france
des stocks
précédemment en amont donc je voudrais
connaître un peu plus les relations qui
qui ont qui existait entre vous enfin
deux questions subsidiaires madame la
ministre
un sur les stocks dans les hôpitaux
évidemment vu l'état de leurs finances
la dette etc
n'était-il pas prévisible qu'ils aient
des difficultés à constituer leurs
propres stocks dans les mesures
nécessaires et enfin qu'avez vous dit à
votre successeur moment voulu avait
passé la main si vous permettez moi
l'impression simplement un complément la
question de bien barré misé sur cette
lettre qui a un effet très importante du
ski à tous dans cette lettre il ya
toutes les alertes sont dans cette
lettre du 26 septembre 2018 rédigé par
monsieur bourg du 26 septembre 2018
rédigé par monsieur bourdillon alors
directeur de santé publique france et
adresser à un professeur jérôme salomon
est ce que vous n'avez jamais une
connaissance de cette lettre
la fin de cette lettre est assez
sidérante
elle indique que 95% des stocks de
médicaments antiviraux détenus par santé
publique francs sont périmés et les
contrôles des masques chirurgicaux on
l'a déjà dit ont mis en évidence une non
conformité à la norme en vigueur sur un
minimum de 60% des stocks donc y aller
de commande vous avez évoqué
l'état des antiviraux notamment les
masques il ya des conclusions
extrêmement alarmante et une demande il
est important qu'une d'autres doctrines
soit rapidement établie par vos services
jamais le professeur salomon a fait
remonter cette alerte ni à vous ni à
votre cabinet alors je n'ai pas
connaissance de ce courrier qu'il
n'avait pas parvenu je n'ai pas eu de
relance voilà je ce que j'ai trouvé mois
dans les archives puisque je me suis la
semaine dernière en raison d'un agenda
personnel puisque je n'ai pas
connaissance de tout ça je le répète je
n'ai pas connaissance 12,5 mais je
retrouve un courrier de santé publique
france au directeur général est récente
et où enfin je sais pas à qui l'adresser
d adresser à des gestes qui est une
réponse à la saisine de 2010 est donc
est une réponse à la saisine d'avril
2010 est de benoît valait donc c'est une
réponse qui fait un état des stocks en
disant voilà ça c'est périmé ça c'est
pas aimer séparé et sa porte sur des
dizaines de produits
donc moi j'ai cette lettre du 3 octobre
ce que j'ai vu dans les documents des
archives qui m'ont été fournis c'est le
directeur général de la santé provoque
une réunion six jours plus tard le 9
octobre
j'espère même pas me tromper dans les
dates mais en tous les cas une semaine
après 20 dans la semaine et que il
envoie un courrier de commandes à santé
publique france le 30 octobre avec toute
la liste des produits
à commander qui concerne vous l'avez
compris des stocks stratégiques de
l'état
on peut pas dire que ce soit pas réactif
puisque pour moi 3 octobre 9 octobre
ça veut dire que le directeur de santé
plus de directeur général de la santé
estime que c'est urgent il organise une
réunion en huit jours et la commande
c'est le temps de lister je suis pas
dans les services j'imagine qu'il ya des
négociations les discussions des avis
qui sont pris pour savoir combien on
commande de chaque produit mais cédé il
ya même des fins dans les stades de
santé but francilien tout il ya y
compris des seringues et des aiguilles y
compris il ya tout faut voir la scène de
question qui se pose c'est des antivirus
et des antibiotiques stratégique pour
les bactéries multirésistantes c'est des
vaccins c'est donc en réalité
pardon excusez moi franchement on est en
en enquête et c'est ça doit être serein
et on en appelle un autre de 6 le dgs
entre le 3 octobre et lui arrive une
lettre que je n'ai pas connaissance de
ces dames je peux pas la commenter
mais ce que j'ai trouvé oui je n'avais
pas causer de blizzard oui oui mais je
ne vais pas elle n'a pas été adressée ce
que j'ai trouvé moins dans les archives
c'est un long courrier du 3 octobre qui
explique tout ce qui est périmé
une réunion du dgs une semaine a prévenu
la semaine et une commande qui part sur
de multiples produits avec 100 millions
de masques le 30 octobre et avec
évidemment l'idée d'une reconstitution
pluriannuel le directeur général de la
santé ne commande pas
d'emblée la totalité des stocks
j'aimais bien pour comprendre ce point
cette lettre que vous dont vous faites
état du 3 octobre c'est une lettre de
monsieur bourdillon à vous-même quoi
c'est une réponse de la saisine du dhs
une réponse de la saisine du dgs sur le
la qualité des stocks d'avril 2010
d'accord c'est bien ce que j'aurais
compris mais comment ce fait-il donc
dans ces archives il est pas la lettre
du 26 septembre qui paraît capital
donc moi je hais ce qu'elle vous a été
caché cela était certainement lé pas
dans les archers les archives du
ministère sont énormes
j'accepte d'abord à mes archives
personnelles du cabinet ça me permet
d'évaluer par exemple j'ai regardé tous
les courriers qui ont été adressés par
santé publique france depuis 2010 est
pour savoir si j'avais vu un courrier
d'alert donc sam a nécessité à faire un
certain temps j'ai j'ai regardé aussi
tous les courriers de janvier 2018 pour
savoir si au moment où moi je prenais
des décisions importantes de paban de
janvier 2020 pour savoir si au moment où
moi je prenais des décisions
stratégiques de préparation de la france
à une épidémie si on m'avait envoyé des
courriers particulier d'alert j'ai reçu
8000 courrier en janvier huit mines donc
voilà on a trié par l'eau clé je ne vois
pas dallaire particules voilà je fais ce
travail de je suis jeune et plus de
cabinet monsieur ciotti
je suis une candidate en campagne pour
la mairie de paris j'écoute vos
auditions quand je rentre le soir
j'essaie de reconstituer parce que vous
m'avez convoqué aujourd'hui avec les
archives je ne dis pas que cette lettre
n'est pas dans les archives je dis que
je n'ai pas trouvé
est ce que c'est que celle que j'ai
trouvé là du 3 octobre et elle liste un
très grand nombre de produits périmés
voilà martine vos nerfs pour le ds
merci beaucoup merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre si vous
voulez bien on va se situer au 30
janvier où vous demander immédiatement
donc à santé publique france des
scénarii en terme de dangerosité est
également donc yazdan yazdanpanah des
protocoles de recherche
étiez vous à ce moment là en contact
avec la chine avez vous regardé quels
étaient les stratégies thérapeutiques en
chine à ce moment-là avez-vous
éventuellement lui l'idée peut-être même
l'avez-vous fait d'envoyer un
commissaire en chine pour savoir si on
pouvait à la fois en parallèle des
protocoles de recherche vous le savez en
tant que médecin qui vont mettre
beaucoup de temps
qui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui n'ont
toujours pas fait preuve de résultat est
ce qu'il y avait peut-être une stratégie
thérapeutique en chine qui montrait déjà
des premiers résultats
ensuite nous sommes mi février vous
décidez de partir pour les municipales
la conseillère médicale de l'elysée a
quitté son poste le 31 janvier donc là
un poste stratégique qui est vides
puisqu'elle ne sera remplacée que début
mars en étiez vous informer le 17 mars
vous donner une interview au journal le
monde
chargée d'émotion vous avez dit que si
c'était en tout cas vous avez remis en
question ce qui s'était passé ce que
vous aviez fait et si c'était à refaire
est-ce que vous changeriez quelque chose
et si oui quoi et notamment validé vous
la stratégie notamment
vous étiez informé donc du manque de
masquer ce mensonge qui a été fait quand
même aux français de dire que les
masques étaient totalement inutile avant
dernière question vos liens d'intérêts
avec l'industrie
pendant combien de temps avec quel
laboratoire est ce que vous pouvez nous
éclairer s'il vous plaît et je vais vous
parler maintenant vous n'êtes plus
ministre
vous êtes donc libre de parole les
etats-unis ont quitté vont arrêter le
financement de l' oms et donc c'est la
fondation bill gates qui aujourd'hui est
le premier financeur est ce que les ex
les essais vaccinaux qui ont lieu depuis
début juin en afrique du sud
est ce que ces essais vaccinaux sont
selon-vous éthiques
merci alors peut-être pour répondre des
sur les essais vaccinaux je ne suis
absolument pas au courant de cette
action je ne suis plus ministre depuis
quatre mois j'étais candidate à la
mairie de paris vous a pas échappé
tout ce que je sache je le sais par la
presse quand j'ai le temps de lire la
presse sur ces sujets là puisque vous le
savez une campagne municipale depuis un
mois beaucoup occupée donc je ne peux
pas vous répond je ne sais pas du tout
ce qui est fait sur le moment où je
demande à monsieur yazd en panne un de
me faire des protocoles et des scénarios
à saint-épiphane ans avait pas le 30
janvier c'est le 25 je préfère le dire
puisque le 30 janvier c'est la
déclaration parle oms de l'urgence de
santé publique internationale et donc
les demandes que je fais elle l'a de
cinq jours avant
et donc je demande aux professeurs et
diamants riazan panneaux qui est un
professeur émérite de infectiologie et
président de la structure réactive qui
est en charge de lutter contre les
épidémies au niveau de la recherche d'or
de coordonner la recherche sur les
épidémies
je lui demande qui me proposent des
protocoles pour tester tout ce qu'on
connaît qui pourrait être utile c'est
dire qui je lui demande d'écrire à
l'avance si une épidémie arrive et elle
arrivera plus d'un mois après quelques
tous les protocoles soient prêts pour
que les premiers malades puissent être
d'emblée inclus dans des essais
cliniques
je n'ai aucune idée les traitements
antiviraux je ne suis pas une
spécialiste de l'infectiologie donc je
lui demande pas spécifiquement de très
détesté un médicament plus qu d'un
plutôt qu'un autre
vous le savez je suis cancérologue je
connais des chimiothérapies donc je ne
me serais pas mêlé en plus voilà les
médicaments beaucoup évolué depuis que
j'ai quitté la clinique
j'ai quitté la clinique il ya plus de
dix ans et donc je ne me permettrais pas
de proposer des traitements donc par
contre je demande au groupe reacting et
alias dans l'iliade en panne à de me
faire des protocoles avec tout ce qu'ils
connaissent c'est tout ce qui existe
c'est de l'anticipation pour moi
[Musique]
à lessines et les scénarios de santé
publique france sur la les évolutions
potentielles de l'épidémie ce pareil je
les demande le 25 janvier et je les
exige en une journée parce que nous
avons une réunion autour du premier
ministre le 26 janvier et je veux
pouvoir présenter au premier ministre
lors de cette première réunion
interministérielle avec mes collègues
l'ensemble des scénarios possibles
je rappelle 26 janvier première réunion
ministre un dimanche à matignon
le ms n'a pas encore déclaré l' urgence
de santé publique internationale
c'est pour ça que je ne peux pas laisser
dire que nous n'avons pas anticipé
donc je ne demande aucun médicament je
n'ai aucune idée des médicaments j'en
suis pas là j'en suis à repérer des
malades sur le territoire identifié les
clos ses contacts avec la chine je
demande en fait à chaque jeu tedros se
ranger des liens réguliers avec tedrow
cheveux que je le connais bien
pardon pour tous ceux qui sont à mettre
un millier tedros c'est le nom du
directeur général de l'om est-ce donc
nous échangeons paroisse de sape et je
sais qu'il va en chine
je l'appelle le jour de son retour pour
essayer d'avoir sa perception de ce qui
se passe je n'arrive pas à la voir ce
jour là mais mon idée c'est vraiment
est-ce qu'il a senti parce que nous
sommes totalement dépendants de ce que
disent les autorités chinoises donc
j'essaye d'avoir des informations
régulières avec lui et tedros envoie un
comité de haut niveau de l' oms en chine
cette semaine je vais vous dire
exactement à quelle date il les envoie
il n'y a pas de français dans ce que
comité de haut niveau
mais bon je fais confiance à mes examens
l'ogre européen et d'idées c'est
justement que c'est comité de haut
niveau
envoyé par le ms voilà c'est le 28
janvier donc il ya une délégation
d'experts de haut niveau de l' oms qui
sera en chine
et l'idée c'est qu'ils nous fassent des
retours plus concret sur ce qui se passe
en chine et donc j'attends évidemment le
retour de ceux de ce comité
mais entre temps j'essaye d'avoir
moi-même tedros allah allah au téléphone
ensuite sur l'article du monde
d'abord ce n'est ni un interview et
encore une déclaration vous l'avez
compris nous sommes un article
journalistes m'appellent un moment j'ai
bataillé contre la fusion des listes
toute la journée nous sommes au deuxième
jour
pardon premiers jours après l'élection
après le premier tour se pose la
question des dépôts de listes
je suis intimement persuadé que le
deuxième tour ne peut pas se tenir
d'ailleurs j'arrête ma campagne je
bataille parce que je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on continue
les tractations politiques les je
demande qu'on arrête c'est à ce moment
là que je suis appelé ça n'est pas un
interview sinon j'aurais relu ses propos
ces verbatim ne m'ont jamais été soumis
et encore moins une déclaration
voilà donc on n'est pas là je pense pour
interpréter ses propos je suis là pour
rendre des comptes devant la
représentation nationale
j'espère clarifier la façon dont j'ai
géré cette crise au moment où j'étais au
ministère est-ce que ensuite sur piles
des niveaux perry avec l'industrie
pharma qui témoignent sur ce point mais
ce que ces propos sont vrais ou pas des
détenus ou non oui souhaitait
sincèrement monsieur le rapporteur
j'avais passé une journée pouvant table
j'étais très fatigué on m'accusait sur
les réseaux sociaux de n'avoir rien vu
et c'est tout le contraire je me suis
battu pendant un mois alors que je
défends des la loi de bioéthique au
sénat cette semaine n'en que j'avais la
loi sur les retraites que j'avais la
grève des hôpitaux les collectifs 21
janvier à tout ça c'est avec la réforme
des retraites
la loi de bioéthique au sénat jour et
nuit et la grève des hôpitaux
tout ça s'est fait sans que personne ne
voie rien quand j'étais au banc au sénat
j'étais en relation avec le premier
ministre ou avec le directeur général de
la santé pour gérer la crise donc que
j'ai dit au monde ce jour-là c'était
arrêter de dire que j'ai rien vu
tout vu j'ai tout vu j'ai préparé cet
article laisse penser que je n'ai pas
préparé
c'est pour ça que je voulais m'expliquer
devant la représentation nationale parce
que j'ai pressenti
j'ai senti un danger bien avant les
autres
le premier ministre l'a tout de suite
perçu avec moi et il a été avec moi en
permanence il m'a fait une confiance
totale
pendant cette période j'ai travaillé
main dans la main avec le gouvernement
avec le m1 avec le premier ministre avec
le directeur général de la santé pour
gérer au mieux préparer au mieux ce
retour d'expérience permettra de voir ce
qu'on trouve ce qu'on peut faire mieux
mais je répondais à ces réseaux sociaux
un article du parisien qui se moquaient
de moi en disant que je n'avais rien vu
et je pense que c'est sur l'article du
monde le rapporteur ensuite sur médias
l'industrie avec elle mais liens
d'intérêts avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
donc je n'ai plus aucun lien d'intérêt
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
depuis que bêtise depuis que je suis
j'ai été nommé à l'institut national du
cancer en 2011
j'avais déjà réduit mes liens d'intérêts
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
lorsque j'étais président de l'iace ce n
est en réalité mes liens avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique se sont
réduits à travailler essentiellement
avec deux laboratoires qui travaillait
sur une maladie mortelle qui s'appelle
la leucémie myéloïde chronique dans les
années 90 ses patientes a été greffé un
sourd de mouret et en 2000 et a réparé a
paru un médicament s'appelle le glee
jacques et qui a été déployé pour sauver
ces gens et donc comme tous les
spécialistes de la leucémie myéloïde
chronique j'ai travaillé avec les deux
laboratoire qui fabriquait ses
médicaments contre une leucémie mortel
pour proposer les traitements me voilà
mes liens d'intérêts je n'en ai plus
depuis très longtemps
merci monsieur 100 de forget
madame la ministre j'entends que vous
avez anticipé j'entends c'est date celle
du 24 janvier c'est en effet la date où
les professionnels de santé reçoivent le
premier mail sur la mailing list des dg
ai tiré sur jean c'est apparemment à
cette date où vous êtes en train de de
faire tout ce que vous pouvez pour que
ça aille plus vite même au niveau le ms
vous vous plaignez que ça vient un peu
tard le 30 janvier seulement
et puis il ya ce rapatriement de one et
à carry le rouet avec pas loin de 200
ressortissants qui revient avec le but
de les tester rapidement d'éviter la
contagion un moment donné où le héros
est pas très évident on ne sait pas la
contagiosité de la maladie mais il ya
une chose incohérente maintenant qui
m'interpelle alors que les personnels
qui vont faire les tests après les pcr
demande de faire les tests soient dans
l'avion soit à istres on leur refuse
apparemment puis vous demandez un comité
de protection des personnes
c'est pour expliquer aux gens c'est en
gros une démarche éthique pour montrer
que dans le cas d'une recherche médicale
vue éthique on va c'est une approche
valable de faire de faire ces tests mais
là on est dans une situation d'urgence
thérapeutique et vous même vous êtes à
l'armée alors pourquoi exiger vous ce
cpp pourquoi faites-vous perdre plus de
24 heures au diagnostic alors que le
personnel de lits achu méditerranée
infection est prêt avec les échos villon
et et vous demandent depuis plusieurs
heures peut peut-être plus à faire à
faire cette démarche diagnostique avec
le risque de contagion contamination
plus importante à ce moment là je vous
souhaitez juste vous poser cette
question
par ailleurs je voudrais juste compte
rester 7,7
ma question juste je le dis grèce un peu
pour vous dire que vous avez beaucoup de
courage est devant nous deux jours après
une échéance électorale un peu difficile
je vous renvoie on vous remercie pour
votre carte et et pour vos précisions
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le député alors
peut-être juste pour revenir sur le
premier des ges urgente c'est important
donc la première alerte vis-à-vis des
professionnels libéraux
donc c'est un mail qui part à huit cent
mille professionnels libéraux
quel que soit leur métier infirmières
kinésithérapeutes médecins acteurs
ce premier des ges urgent est parti le
14 janvier
ce sont mes comptes rendus écoutez j'ai
tous les comptes rendus du corps ' on
recommence pas voilà j'ai tous les
comptes rendus du chorus les contrôles
du chorus et le 10 janvier
alerte aux ars aux sociétés savantes et
le 14 janvier
alerte sanitaire aux établissements est
déjà sûre je vois là les contres après
moi je ne peux pas voilà je ne peux pas
je ne suis pas moi-même recettes le
récepteur de ces alertes ges qui sont
dans les comptes rendus du du centre de
crise et peut-être pourrez-vous les
récupérer d'ailleurs j'imagine que alors
ensuite sur les task des rapatriés de
one j'ai demandé dans la semaine au
moment on organiser le rapatriement des
français de one au professeur yazdan
yazdanpanah et à toutes les équipes qui
allaient accueillir le lapin qui étaient
susceptibles d'accueillir des des
rapatriés de me proposer un document de
consentement éclairé sur les tests et
donc j'ai demandé un comité de
protection des personnes de valider ce
test de consomac et pourquoi parce que
quand les rapatriés arrive nous ne
savons absolument pas ce qu'on doit
faire
si jamais par exemple une personne et
testées négatives parce qu'il faut lui
refaire le test le lendemain le
surlendemain j'ai demandé à un groupe
d'experts de réfléchir à ce qu'on doit
proposer rapatriés
en fait quand l'avion arrive le 31 je
suis à l'accueil
ils sont épuisés ce sont des gens
épuisés ils ont été confinés à one
pendant huit jours dans l'appartement
sans savoir s'il allait pouvoir rentrer
en france
tous n'étaient pas sûrs de rentrée
c'était assez compliqué de trier les
gens à l'aéroport parce qu'il y avait
des questions de passeports de
binationalité
est-ce qu'on prenait dans l'avion les
gens malades ou pas est-ce que des gens
qui avaient des petits symptômes on les
prenait quand même à ce qu'on les isoler
dans l'avion qu'est ce qu'on leur
faisait et donc il ya une forme de tri
qui se fait à l'aéroport ce sont des
gens qui ont marché à pied pour
rejoindre les bus parfois en traversant
la ville de one sur des kilomètres en
traînant leurs valises une ville déserte
y a pas de transport ils sont appelés
par l'ambassade de france ils vont à un
endroit on les emmène en bus à
l'aéroport ils attendent à l'aéroport
je sais pas combien d'heures pour être
triées ils sont pas sûrs de pouvoir
partir ils ont 12 heures d'avion ils
arrivent à istres et je vois des gens
éreintait avec des enfants tout le monde
avait des menaces et nous on fait un
nouveau tri et c'est l'armée qui
l'organisent de façon absolument
remarquable vraiment c'est le service de
santé des armées qui met en place une
tente d'abord on leur donne collation
une je sais pas comment on appelle ça un
arrêté de mise sous quarantaine qu'on a
signés parce qu'en réalité on va les
enfermer et donc c'est l'article l 31 31
du code de santé publique qui me permet
d'obliger les gens à rester en
quarantaine alors que certains
pourraient avoir envie de rentrer dans
leur famille donc on leur donne un
document qui leur dit vous n'aurez pas
le droit de sortir et voilà ce qu'on va
vous faire vous serez en quarantaine
enfermé dans une chambre d'hôtel etc
terran et il arrive dans la base et et
on trie sur la base disent les gens qui
ont des symptômes
les gens qui ont des symptômes je crois
qu'il y en a trois si mes souvenirs sont
bons sont envoyés à marseille ou sachets
pour être testé les autres ils vont bien
et donc je dis on les met en quarantaine
on les nourrit on les laisse dormir et
demain demain matin on leur fait un test
et des enfants issus des familles et
demain on leur fait un test en leur
donnant un protocole qui leur disent
qu'on va faire si le test est positif
s'il est négatif si on les autres et
c'est pas moi décidé je demande un
comité d'experts de décider pour moi
voilà je je n'ai pas effectivement
autorisé qu'on fasse des tests à des
personnes en bonne santé
épuisés qui vont être mises en
quarantaine dans une chambre d'hôtel en
fermer ça aurait apporté quoi va sauf de
les stresser et le lendemain quand ils
sont reposés ils ont un consentement
éclairé avec un avis d'un comité
d'éthique
ils sont tous testés ils savent surtout
ce qu'on fait des tests s'ils sont
positifs ou négatifs
est ce qu'on les hospitalisés ce qu'on
voit là c'est ça que j'ai préparé parce
que je voulais que ça soit fait dans le
bonheur merci alors je fais faire poser
les questions maintenant par trois
personnes un groupe de trois voilà je me
comprends alors d'abord jean pierre door
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
j'ai presque envie de dire que vous êtes
passé de la lumière à l'ombre mais vous
revenez de avec nous ce soir donc c'est
quand même mieux
vous n'êtes plus en lumière que cuillère
votre comparaison avec les pays
étrangers en domaine de ne me plaît pas
du tout car je pense que le plan
pandémique vous connaissiez en tant que
responsable de la haute autorité de
santé l'époque plan pandémie 2011 était
un plan pandémique est à l'avant-garde
de tous les pays européens et même et
pays mondiaux qui avait été mis sous la
direction de votre collègue que le
professeur houssin
je pense que la doctrine 2013 et la
fusion dans leur agence santé publique
france ont été assez délétère dans le
domaine de l'évolution de ce plan
pandémie mais question va être courte
parce que le ministère de la santé a la
tutelle de l'eprus il doit faire c'est
dans la loi le renouvellement de tous
les matériels périmés chaque année or je
ne sais pas si ça a été fait réguler de
façon régulière chaque année et cela
m'amène au financement le financement de
l'eprus appartenait moitié
assurance-maladie moitié état je n'ai
jamais revu le financement de l'eprus
dans les plf essais successifs
ou est ce que s'est passé et enfin
dernière question monsieur bourdillon a
déclaré ne pas avoir les moyens pour
acheter les stocks de masques
alors est-ce que ça s'adressait au
ministère de la santé ou à bercy où ont
été les réponses négatives pour pas
avoir ses moyens pour pouvoir renouveler
cette fameuse lettre qui a été adressée
la lettre d'appel de septembre 2018
voilà je vous remercie
ensuite monsieur penchèrent
bien madame la mise j'avais trois
questions précises à vous poser d'abord
revenir sur l'article l'article du monde
il faut qu'on ait les réponses à ces
questions vous disiez avoir alerté le
directeur général de la santé dès le 11
janvier et le président macron je crois
au même moment sur l'ampleur de la crise
est ce que vous confirmez l'avoir fait à
cette époque sous quelle forme et qu'on
quels ont été les réponses
deuxième question cet article vous prête
des propos suivants que vous auriez
également alerté le premier ministre 30
janvier en expliquant que les élections
municipales pourrait pas avoir lieu le
15 mars
est-ce que vous avez alerté
effectivement le premier ministre sur ce
sujet là sous quelle forme et quelle a
été sa réponse rappelle que vous venez
de prêter serment et c'est une question
importante parce que les français ont
été troublés par là les conditions de
tenue des élections municipales du 1er
tour avec évidemment toutes les
incidences qu'on connaît dernière
dernière question on découvre finalement
une bureaucratie mais vraiment infernal
dans la gestion du matériel de
protection en cas de crise
est ce que vous étiez vraiment courant
de l'ampleur des besoins de stocks de
sécurité parce qu'il ya un moment on va
pas tous pouvoir se renvoyer la patate
chaude comme ça on est arrivés démasqué
en début de crise il n'y avait pas de
comment il n'y avait pas de test alors
on voit bien que santé publique france
ce n'est qu'une agence une boîte aux
lettres son ancien directeur dit mais on
a alerté bon c'est directeur général de
la santé pour faire le cabinet le
ministre est pas est pas informée d'une
crise pareille
je rappelle quand même que 600 millions
de tests de masques pardon à peut-être
10 centimes 15 centimes à l'époque c'est
6 7 millions d'euros quoi à peine c'est
un budget du ministère de la santé on a
quand même besoin d'avoir des réponses
précises à ce type de questions merci
madame la ministre
[Musique]
alors pour répondre au député d'or
excusez moi j'avais oublié encore
quelqu'un a ni gêne t pardon merci
madame président merci madame ministre
pour vos propos éclairants séquence
chronologique est tout à fait
éclairantes
j'ai été d'abord journée toboggan
préambule confirmé deux choses
j'ai moi même comme médecin était
destinataire de deux sms qui m'ont
d'ailleurs tellement étonné que j'en ai
retenu les dates qui étaient les 10 et
14 janvier je suis demandé pourquoi
j'étais destinataires de sein est un
médecin n'exerçant donc je confirme et
j'avais été frappé par la précocité des
messages reçus et après j'ai reçu comme
tous mes confrères les messages des ges
urgents qui notamment précisait la
définition des cas qu'on a vu tout à
fait évolué au cours du temps en
fonction des informations que vous
receviez des observations vous pouvez
faire je voudrais également confirmé
l'épopée absolument dingue des français
de buran c'est ma circonscription je
connais bien j'ai été en contact avec
eux et rappeler aussi que maurane qui
était vite vous le rappeliez a été en
période de nouvel an chinois qui fait
que la vie c'était moitié de la moitié
vide et de la moitié de sa population et
c'était extrêmement compliqué de ce fait
de circuler dans vos veines à ce moment
là donc c'est de confirmation que je
tenais à apporter
ensuite j'ai été frappé par le
témoignage que vous avez apporté de 28
vous avez je me suis mais quand même on
a un ministre de la santé qui est se
trouve être un médecin
ça aurait pu ne pas être le cas et donc
vous raconter cet épisode du 25 décembre
vous avez vu ce blog qui vous a alerté
sur des cas de pneumonie inexpliqué donc
les nommer question c'est mais vous avez
également théorie de ces discordances
entre les 50 cas en chine et le cas
importés en france à bordeaux également
la discordance vous l'avez évoqué entre
les symptômes qui apparaissent
relativement mineures dans ce que
décrivent les chinois y compris quand
leur nombre de cas commencent à
augmenter
et puis nous ce que nous observons nous
dans nos hôpitaux et finalement je me
suis dit mais si vous n'aviez pas été
médecin qui pouvaient alerté le ministre
de la santé sur ces discordances qui
pouvait en avoir l'intuition
le comité scientifique a été mis en
place un peu plus tard
après le nettement plus tard n'était
plus ministre a seulement la jouer un
petit peu à voir votre votre témoignage
là dessus et puis un dernier point sur
la commande du 7 février dont vous avez
parlé la commande équipements vous
pouvez vous préciser le type de matériel
que vous avez commandé les quantités et
sur quelle doctrine vous avez commandé
ces matériels est acquis alors d'abord
pour répondre sur de financement de
l'eprus je n'ai pas d'historique des
financements des prusse monsieur d'or je
sais ce que j'ai trouvé en arrivant
puisque santé santé publique france
allait absorber l'eprus et le
financement de cette agence avait été
transféré comme un certain nombre
d'agents d'ailleurs entièrement à
l'assurance maladie
alors est ce que c'est en 2017 2018 ou
2016 je ne sais pas je peux pas vous
répondre mais je pense que les services
pourront vous répondre mais il ya eu un
certain nombre d'agents ce qu'avait des
financements croisés de multiples
tutelle qui progressivement et est
considérée comme faisant partie des
agences en charge de la santé des
français qui sont financés par
l'assurance maladie
c'était 50 % est à 50% voilà mais je ne
sais pas si le financement des ce pru
s'est passé à l'assurance maladie pour
moi j'étais aux affaires je ne me
souviens plus parce que je sais qu'il ya
eu une agence qui est passé ou si
c'était du temps de marisol touraine je
peux je ne peux pas vous le dire les
agences font l'objet d' comme toutes les
agences et un dialogue
budgétaire au moment de leur conseil
d'administration de la construction du
budget donc voilà ce que nous avons une
alerte particulière sur le financement
des pruches je ne dirais pas plus et pas
moins que toutes les agences puisque
vous le savez on a demandé l étain
globalement aux administrations aux
agences de d'être sobre dans les années
qui qui étaient les années de rigueur
budgétaire mais ni plus ni moins que les
autres enfin c'est une agence qui est
alors la de multiples missions sentait
plus de france
elle tient les registres la surveillance
du territoire est en fait il semblait
que la fusion des trois agences et
russie une psp est ce permettent de
faire un certain nombre d'économies sur
les fonctions de support dont il y avait
une certaine logique à ne pas rentrer je
crois que la première année de le budget
a été renouvelé à l'identique mais après
on a considéré que les fonctions de
support ce mutualisant il n'y avait pas
besoin de trois services financiers de
trois services de communication et a
donc fait partie mais je n'ai pas eu d'
alerte particulière sur les financements
de l'eprus sur la bureaucratie et et
d'ailleurs je pense que on s'interroge
tout sur eux
sur la question de quelle serait la
meilleure organisation à venir moi je
pense qu'en période de crise alors c'est
mon sentiment profond mais parce que
j'ai géré notre crise à lire et c'est là
que j'ai mal je pense que ça ne peut pas
être les mêmes personnes qui gèrent le
temps long et qui gère les crises je
pense que le mode de fonctionnement
d'une gestion du temps long et le mode
de fonctionnement et de gestion de crise
qui doit être hyper réactif et très en
anticipation se sont généralement pas du
tout les mêmes compétences et je pense
qu'il faut une agence dédiée aux crises
en général mais pas seulement crise
sanitaire
parce que je les ai vus en général écrit
sont intriqués je les ai vus avec
lubrizol lubrizol c'est un truc et c'est
environnemental c'est chimie
x7 santé publique en fait si vous n'avez
qu'une agence que dédié aux crises
sanitaires vous ratez souvent et c'est
compliqué de recoller les morceaux dans
d'autres pays ce sont deux ce sont je
crois
doté d' agence dédiée aux crises et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que la personne responsable de ce type
d' agences elle rend des comptes mais
uniquement sur sa gestion de crise alors
que quand s'est diluée dans une agence
plus face et voilà il ya peut-être que
ça réduit la capacité ou la réactivité
jeu je pense que c'est vraiment
d'enseignements qu'on doit peut-être
tiré de cette crue donc vous parler du
rqra si je ne veux pas le qualifier je
ne sais pas moi j'ai eu les réponses sur
les stocks de masques quand je les ai
demandé quand j'ai demandé où on était
des stocks de masques
en janvier on m'a répondu assez
rapidement je crois en l'espace de deux
jours un jour deux là après j'ai passé
des commandes
peut-être pour revenir sur la question
des commandes puisque j'en parle donc il
ya une première commande le 2 février
quand je décide de constituer un stock
d'état et donc ça c'est une décision
ministre jeudi
voilà on va suppléer aux masques ffp2 et
ce stock d'état qui n'existent pas parce
que si ça se trouve
tout le monde n'est pas prêt malgré
l'aide parce que la doctrine de
dominants dont on n'est pas sûr qu'elle
soit comprise ou adam vraiment appliquée
et ensuite congés les remontées de
toutes les agences régionales de santé
donc c'est la note que le dgs reçoit le
6 février le 7 février
nous faisons partir une commande avec
plus aisément
une demande alors je sais pas moi qui
défile c'est pas moi qui décide des
chiffres un mois jacte de la commande
jacques globalement de la commande donc
les chiffres sont proposés par les
services c'est normal c'est pas moi qui
fait les calculs des besoins journaliers
en masques et donc il ya une commande
qui partent 28 millions de ff p2 de gand
3 million deux cent mille charlotte
50000 lunettes 200 milles sur chaussures
100 millilitres de de solution hydro
alcoolique avec je le dis un scénario de
distribution aux médecins libéraux
infirmières et pharmaciens et aux aides
par des aux établissements simple voilà
et c'est à ce moment là que on réalise
les tensions sur la production est en
fait là la difficulté de recevoir donc
ça c'est aussi je pense la grande leçon
de cette crise et la nécessité de
diversifier d'être souverain en termes
de capacités de production mais surtout
de diversifier et d'ailleurs ça rejoint
le plan que j'avais écrit sur les
pénuries de médicaments puisque j'avais
présenté l'année dernière un plan sur
les pénuries de médicaments j'avais bien
noté trois choses 1 qu'il fallait
diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement parce que c'était
trop centralisée de qu'il fallait des
stocks de trois mois en france pour tous
les médicaments indispensables là je
pense que pour les stocks
c'est aussi probablement ce qu'on
devrait demander aux établissements de
santé voire des stocks de trois mois ça
n'était pas précisément la doctrine de
et j'avais une troisième chose qui
m'échappe oui et là où j'avais vu dans
le plan médicaments où j'avais dit qu'il
fallait commencer à travailler sur une
relocalisation de la production des
médicaments en europe
voilà donc je trouve que en fait ce plan
pénurie de médicaments il correspond
assez bien ce qu'on a vécu en termes de
retours d'expérience sur cette crise
ensuite sur la question de madame rabot
madame la députée c'est sur le pardon
pas encore pardon non excusez moi c'est
monsieur excusez moi désolé j'avais mon
regard vers vous pardon monsieur le
député donc sur l'alerté au monde la
leyre du 30 janvier
là aussi c'est un pressentiment le 30
janvier je vous raconte l'histoire notre
en janvier nous sommes avec le premier
ministre en train de lancer la grande
conférence sur le financement des
retraites aux saisons et nous
travaillons trois heures avec toutes les
organisations syndicales pour actes et
qu'ils doivent nous remettre un rapport
sur le financement des retraites et le
fameux âge pivot fin avril
et puis nous attendons à la fin de la
réunion dans un grand bureau avec une
vingtaine de personnes et la discussion
est une discussion de salon et je crois
que de voir philippe évoque le fait
qu'il va se présenter wavre et je lui
dis si cette épidémie progresse et si
elle arrive en europe
zoom le 30 janvier donc c'est le jour je
le rappelle c'est le jour où l' oms
déclare une urgence de santé publique à
l'internaute de portée internationale
il n'y a pas mille cas en chine et je
lui ai dit si ça se trouve les élections
pourront pas se tenir
c'est une phrase dont je me souviens
parce que j'ai vu la réaction du premier
ministre jeudi ben oui si jamais cette
épidémie chinoise devient une épidémie
mondiale
il est possible qu'en mars est possible
alors ait pu arriver en avril
elle aurait pu arriver qu'un jour avant
quinze jours plus tard trois semaines
plus tard
bon voilà force est de constater que le
deuxième tour n'a pas eu lieu
donc cette phrase que j'ai lancée de
façon c'est pas c'est pas une alerte
formel nous étions dans le salon du cee
et voilà on était un groupe de personnes
avec le premier ministre
valérie rabault oui bonsoir madame
ministre j'aurai trois petites questions
la première est ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'un ministre pendant 15 mois
c'est à dire entre octobre 2018 et
janvier 2020 ne soit pas qu'on met pas
remonter l'information sur l'état des
masques sur cette fameuse lettre
d'octobre 2018
est ce que c'est normal que vous vouliez
pas l'information que dans le fond la
france
en tout cas les français ne sont plus
protégés deuxième question est ce que à
votre connaissance quand vous êtes parti
vous aviez connaissance du stop en
termes d' anesthésique propofol et c est
ce que c'était un stock de moi un mois
en période normale je parle
et est-ce qu'il y avait eu une
évaluation en termes de stress tests
s'il fallait augmenter comme ça a été le
cas les besoins pour la réanimation
enfin c'est mon troisième point est plus
une remarque qu'une question j'étais un
peu chagriné d'antan tout à l'heure que
vous lisiez que telle et parlementaire
est intervenu pour les premières
questions le 24 janvier 2020 et après
vous avez parlé des pénuries médicaments
mois il se trouve que je vous ai écrit
le 13 décembre 2017
j'ai retrouvé la lettre sur les pénuries
de médicaments qu'on n'avait jamais
répondu je vous ai réécrit en 2018
j'ai interrogé premier ministre lors des
questions au gouvernement le 19 juin
2019 et vous avez lancé le plan pénurie
de médicaments dont je voudrais juste
rappeler qu'il n'est pas tout à fait
exact que vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure les parlementaires sur les
pénuries de médicaments vous ont
interrogé moi j'ai pas eu de réponse
peut-être que d'autres ont eu des
réponses
je vous remercie d'avoir bougé le 11
juillet 2010 9 ans est le premier
ministre mais nous avons dû aller jusqu
à l'interroger lui aux questions
gouvernement parce que nous n'avions pas
de réponse de votre ministère je vous
remercie
merci je mange je reviens je sais plus
qui m'a posé la question tout à l'heure
que je n'avais pas appeler monsieur
houssin ça me revient à l'esprit
désolé non j'ai appelé monsieur tedros
en fait je connais très bien tedros pour
moi
mon homologue c'est directeur général de
la douane s je l'appelle pas les
services ministre n'appelle pas je sais
pas si les aides - 2ème mois 3 et moi
car je n'en sais rien mais ça c'est le
directeur général de la santé qui est en
lien avec les services techniques de
l'oms oui mais objectivement moi mon
lien et le nombre de textos que nous
avons avec pedros a depuis que il a été
nommé à la direction générale de l'eau
et masse c'est mon homologue c'est mon
interlocuteur c'est lui que je rencontre
quand je vais à la messe je ne rencontre
personne d'autre que tedros voilà donc
je me permets de dire que je après le
dgs est en lien régulier avec les
services techniques de la ms je sais pas
à quel niveau et je lui demande pas
qu'il a comme contacter chacun son
niveau de contact ensuite sur les
pénuries de médicaments malabo je me
suis mal exprimé
la question je dis simplement sur le
coronavirus des pénuries de médicaments
en fait la question qui est posée en
février c'est des pénuries de
médicaments qui serait liée à l'épidémie
en chine par fermeture des usines en
chine
c'est de ça dont je parle je dis pas
vous n'avez pas alerté avant c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a fait un plan
sur les pénuries des médicaments dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure je dis
simplement sur le coronavirus des
questions des parlementaires ont été à
la date du 28 janvier sur one est sûre
en fait le rapatriement et en février
sur le risque de pénurie de médicaments
ensuite sur les stocks d'anesthésiques
l'une ministre ne connaît pas les stocks
des milliers de produits de santé dont
on a besoin dans un système de santé
joshua imaginer que c'est pas parce que
aujourd'hui un problème émergent et qu'
il est la focalisation et et c'est
normal de l'attention que la ministre
doit forcément savoir un an avant
quel est le stock d'un produit parmi
cent mille donc
gers et refaire l'histoire de personne
ne peut demander ça une ministre ma
personne je ne souhaite jamais à mes
futurs et olivier verrons mais même à
mes père et prédécesseur de s'interroger
pour savoir combien il ya dans pool de
propos fond de chute pas quoi en france
pas possible les cris sont multi
peut-être qu'un jour on aura besoin d'un
produit x je sais pas quel antibiotiques
sera utile pour une bactérie
multirésistante on peut pas demander à
la ministre un an avant de savoir que ce
stock de bach t2 d'antibiotiques exister
à quelle dose enfin donc en réalité ce
qui compte c'est d'avoir l'information
rapidement et ce qui compte c'est de
pouvoir commander est en réalité ce que
nous a montrée cette crise c'est que
quand on a commandé mais il y avait plus
moyen d'en avoir
c'est ça la réalité en fait quand on a
commandé les produits le 30 janvier
première commande de 7 février deuxième
commande tout est produit en chine et
plus rien arriver les avions sont
arrêtés les trucs arrivent par bateau ce
qui est parti par bateau sané amant pour
arriver là on est face à quelque chose
d'inédit est ce que ça nous je pense que
ça nous dit cette crise c'est que on n'a
pas vu la centralisation de la
production et c'est peut-être vrai pour
d'autres produits donc il va falloir
faire ce travail est le pire d'ailleurs
c'est que ce n'est pas seulement là cela
il faut pas simplement regarder quels
sont les usines qui produisent il faut
regarder ou fait la matière première le
principe actif
c'est là où on a été piégé sur les sur
blues quand vous apprenez que la
production du tissu qui sera farley sur
12 l etat one et que la ville est fermée
depuis quinze jours c'est ça c'est ça
qu'on doit régler parce que sincèrement
si on avait pu acheter en temps réel les
commandes on n'aurait pas été dans la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui
donc moi
je veux bien qu'on me dise que j'ai pas
anticipé mais d'anticipation allait bien
au-delà elle est l'anticipation du
commerce mondial de la production
centralisée du fait qu'on délocalise du
fait que et que la malchance c'est que
cette épidémie elle part de chine parce
que franchement elle serait parti de
thaïlande
le problème n'aurait pas été le même
voilà juge
[Musique]
alors après on poser la question du napt
période de chauffe
moi je savais que c'était olivier
verrons qui me succéder à 100 c'était
une évidence pour tout le monde
il avait déjà été pressenti comme
ministre roman en 2010 est donc c'était
c'était une évidence été rapporteur
général du plfss
il était rapporteur d'une partie de la
loi de bioéthique il était rapporteur
d'une partie de la loi sur les retraites
le projet de loi organique
donc il connaissait tous les dossiers du
mystère aux différents je l'avais tout
le temps au téléphone il était tout le
temps d'un ministère tout le temps dans
les réunions
il connaît le ministère comme sa poche
il l'a été voilà il a fait il a fait des
missions quand il était député autour la
tarification à l'activité et connaît
tous les services du ministère et
connaît le dgs
c'était c'était une passation de pouvoir
d'une simplicité
je lui ai dit comment je vais dit voilà
tout est mis en tension
maintenant cette épidémie elle va
probablement arriver en europe
on a parlé des matériels des commandes
de ce qui avait été lancée on va parler
que de ça le reste ça ne s'est même pas
posée vous l'avez dit monsieur le député
le problème majeur c'est en fait le
problème de la production
en fait ça a touché tous les pays du
monde
parce qu'en fait on a été en compétition
quand on voit que il y avait des
batailles sur les tarmacs des aéroports
pour récupérer les stocks
elles étaient tous les pays ont été
confrontés au même problème moi j'ai les
collègues médecins dans différents pays
ils ont aussi eu des pénuries détention
moi-même à percy j'ai senti des
difficultés sur les sur blues et sur les
masques ffp2 c'est une réalité
c'est pas parce que nous n'avons pas
anticipé et que quand nous avons lancé
les commandes et nous avons anticipé
nous avons lancé des commandes très tôt
en réalité la production était déjà en
chine et les frontières fermées
il rapporte à vous lire ajouté oui merci
à madame la présidente peut-être pour
pour conclure cette cette audition très
très dense vous en remercier madame la
ministre
question de nature budgétaire ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure nos collègues je
crois par jean pierre door
il ya eu un transfert du financement de
santé publique france du plf vers le
plfss
est-ce que sur la méthode ça n'éloigne
pas d'ailleurs le le contrôle direct de
l'état sur cette mission prévention de
sécurité sur la sécurité sanitaire
est ce que le fait pour des raisons
budgétaires de transférer le financement
au budget de la sécurité sociale ne
prive pas l'état et en l'occurrence
votre ministère d'un outil de contrôle
et de pilotage et votre audition à
montrer quand même que que ce qu'il
otages faisait cruellement défaut
puisque vous nous avez dit qu'à aucun
moment vous n'avez été informé de la
baisse
j'ose dire dramatique de tous les stocks
et notamment de ceux des masques donc
est-ce que sept pilotes ce pilotage n'a
pas fait défaut vous nous avez dit on ne
pas connaître les stocks sur des
produits multiples j'en conviens mais ô
combien bon temps et stratégique donc
qui les connaissaient vraiment et est ce
que quelqu'un est responsable du non
renouvellement de ses stocks à quel
stade est ce que celle des jet skis lui
les connaissent et qui n'a pas assuré la
mission de renouvellement est ce que
c'est santé publique france mais
pourquoi ceux qui connaissaient puisque
vous nous dites que vous même ne les
connaissez pas non pas assurer cette
mission vous nous indiquez l'instant
avoir commandé très tôt les
les stocks de produits essentiels de
protection moi je dirais que c'est
plutôt très tard parce que naturellement
une anticipation rédu faire en sorte que
n'importe quelle crise arrivant nous
soyons doté de ses produits ses
équipements et notamment des des masques
donc question sur le budget sur la
gestion des stocks et enfin je voudrais
vous interrogé mardi sur le recours à
des cabinets de consultants privés
ministère de la santé et des
établissements publics de santé ont pris
l'habitude de mobiliser des cabinets
d'audit d'audit je pense en particulier
à mckinsey qui sont intervenus sur des
opérations de restructuration d'hôpitaux
de diminution des coûts de diminution
des effectifs mais de façon un peu plus
étonnante ils ont été mobilisés dans la
gestion de la crise est ce que c'est
vous qui avait passé commande à ces
cabinets d'audit dans quel cadre de
commandes publiques et sur la forme et
sur le fond est ce que c'est vraiment
pertinent que l'état sauf à être
totalement démunis dans sa vision
stratégique recours à des cabinets
d'audit et de consulting qui ont eu à
gérer la crise et notamment je crois la
task force pour faire monter en
puissance
le nombre de tests c'est mobilisation
qui personnellement me m'interroge je
commence par les cabinets d'audit je ne
suis pas au courant qu'il ait eu un
recours aucun cabinet pendant 2
parce que je pense que ça a dû se faire
après mon départ
donc moi je n'ai pas vu j'ai pas
actionner ce levier
ensuite vous de regretter et je le
comprends qu'il n'y ait pas eu une
anticipation avant la commande de deux
mille du 2 février et du 9 et pas les du
7 février
je ne vois pas alors excusez moi c'est
plutôt un retour d'expérience qu'on doit
faire collectivement je ne vois pas
pourquoi j'aurais anticiper une commande
de masques ffp2 alors que cela ne
relevait plus là des stocks stratégiques
ont changé je parlais des masses grand
public moi je n'ai pas commandés de
masse grand public le 2 février et le 9
février j'ai recommandé des stocks des
temps des fêtes les deux pour les
soignants j'ai créé un stock d'état qui
n'existaient pas et pour les masques
grand public
les masques chirurgicaux orgeco une
commande était déjà en cours donc quand
j'ai interrogé sur le stock de masques
il y avait une commande qui devait être
réalisé sans réveiller donc moi ce que
j'ai commandé
si j'ai commandé un produit qui n'était
pas de la responsabilité de l'état
je les fais très en anticipation pour
protéger les soignants c'est la commande
que j'ai passé le 2 et le 7 février
en fait non le 2 février excusez-moi
j'ai 4 janvier non j'ai passé la
commande de 30 janvier qui le 2 février
j'ai hâte et qu'il fallait un stock
stratégie déteint sur les fleuves p2 ce
qui n'était pas la doctrine jusqu'à
présent puisque en 2011 on avait dit que
la sfp 2 n'était plus à la charge de
l'état
donc je re j'ai recréé le 2 février un
stock d'état ffp2 et la commande est
parti de 30 janvier en jean pull puis le
7 février
voilà ce que j'ai comme un oui n'est pas
si vous permettez madame la ministre là
dessus pour voilà je veux pas je reviens
sur le les masques chirurgicaux
il ya cette note cette demande de santé
publique france 26 septembre 2018 qui
dit il faut un milliard de masques
chirurgicaux les stocks s'amenuisent
jusqu'à arriver autour de 100 millions
un peu plus selon monsieur salomon un
peu moins selon madame chen au 1er
janvier 2020 ça veut dire que là on est
totalement démunis je vous rappelle que
le besoin cas de crise et de 500
millions par semaine on est à 100
millions ça veut dire c'est à peine une
journée d'utilisation peux t'assurer
commandes d'un million je leur dis moi
je 2 je déclare qu'il faut un stock
d'état stratégique respect d'eux je crée
je me demande comment des deux mais
surtout jeu comme je demande le 25
janvier qu'on fasse remonter des ars les
besoins cette commande d'un million elle
correspond pas aux besoins elle
correspond lancé une première commande
en attendant les remontées terrain
sachant qu'en théorie c'est à la charge
des établissements des professionnels de
s'équiper en théorie selon la doctrine
de domino donc cette commande de 1
million elle n'est pas censée répondre
aux besoins elle est censée dire on n'a
aucune remontée drs une en commande je
ne sais pas d'où est sorti ce chiffre je
ne peux pas vous le dire c'est pas c'est
pas moi qui dit un million mais en
réalité c'est une commande temporaire en
attendant d'avoir des remontées terrain
et c'est sur les remontées de terrain
des ars sur les stocks dans les
établissements que la deuxième commande
pas et elle est beaucoup plus importante
puisque je vous le rappelle la
préoccupation de la ministre c'est pas
que les masques c'est tout c'est toutes
les commandes
je les commande elles sont pas juste des
masques sont quand je demande le 25
janvier ce la préparation des
établissements je demande des
respirateurs les lits de réanimation les
matériels de circulation extracorporelle
je demande à totalité des masques en
font qu'une partie
après vous me dites comment se fait-il
et vous savez quand ces matériels arrive
notamment les respirateurs jeu
je n'ai pas le souvenir d'avoir moi
commander des respirateurs moi j'ai
demandé qu'on le fasse l'état des lieux
de ce qui existait pour savoir combien
on en avait et savoir s'il fallait en
recommandé moi personnellement je n'ai
pas dans cette commande
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas le chiffre
personnellement dans la note que j'ai
récupéré de la dèche est yahia pas çi
fais pas çi je ne peux pas vous le dire
mais la demande que j'ai faite le 25
janvier ses membres de respirateurs sur
le qui connaissait les stocks
le dgs que des stocks la ministre ne
connaît pas le niveau des stocks mais le
déjà ce lieu c'est le problème qu'on a
eu c'est c'est pas la quantité
c'est que le dgs découvre que les stats
son périmètre le dgs il à la notion qui
à 600 millions de masques 2018
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
il ya quelqu'un il ya quelqu'un qui est
en charge connaître les stocks santé
publique france va faire remonter de
façon annuelle l'état des stocks
le dgs à cette remontée 2010 par an et
demi en 2018 oui il a ça fait partie des
relations entre l'agencé avec des ges
que d'avoir l'état des stocks de des ges
le sait ce qui est inattendu
c'est pas le nombre c'est que santé
publique france qui est censé avoir un
rôle d'établissement pharmaceutique gère
un stock et tout d'un coup ce stock est
périmé donc il n'y a pas pendant donc
aujourd'hui
excusez moi en terme de pilotage pardon
parce que vous avez rocher la question
de 8 du pilotage c'est ça que je cherche
c'est pas le passage à la de l'assurance
maladie qui change le pilotage de santé
publique france il ya beaucoup d'
agences maintenant qu'ils sont financés
par l'assurance maladie de la plupart
des agences ont passé un financement
assurance m'a dit ça ne change rien au
pilotage de l'agent ça n'est que un
tuyau budgétaire c'est toujours la dgs
qui siège au conseil d'administration de
santé publique france à ma connaissance
il n'y a pas de remontée spécifique au
conseil d'administration par santé
publique france 2 la question des stocks
à mon niveau je n'ai jamais eu une
alerte spécifique du de santé publique
france sur les stocks ni en arrivant
comme ministre ni après et quand j'ai
dit sur des stocks c'est encore moins
sur les masques la question des masques
tels que moi je l'appréhendais elle
apparaît au ministère le 22 janvier
quand je l'aimais ce déclarent une
transmission interhumaine est il que je
veux dit faut qu'on se prépare à une
épidémie et que je lance et
rétroactivement vous avez le regret que
le directeur général de la santé nous
est pas informée des éléments qui
l'avait en sa reconnaissance sur cette
pénurie écouter les besoins tel
qu'évalué dans le rapport ce talent sont
encore une fois il faut vous remettre
les choses en l'état je je je comprends
l'interrogation mais les besoins ils
sont évalués sur l'hypothèse qu'il y
aurait 20 millions de personnes
atteintes en même temps de la grippe
c'est ça dit peut-être on est on est sur
une tendance mais grippale alors
effectivement on n'a pas un milliard de
masques en stock
on peut le regretter pour une pandémie
grippale mais le quorum mai mais ces
masques là ils sont faits pour être
donnés aux malades avec une boîte pour
la famille ça l'hypothèse du rapport
donc
ce rapport d'ici à vingt millions de
malades il faut que dans 20 millions de
foyers français ya une boîte de masques
à aucun moment personne n'a pu se
projeter que le coronavirus vu sa
mortalité pouvait atteindre 20 millions
de français ça serait démentiel je
rappelle qu'avec 10 millions de
personnes atteintes dans le monde
on est à cinq cent mille morts donc on
est on est sur un autre type de virus
personne ne peut imaginer pour l'as
évoluer une épidémie à 20 millions mais
pour ça c'est pour ça que le confinement
est la seule méthode parce que les
masques
le problème de ce virus vous le savez
c'est qu'il se contaminent à la fois par
des buttes littoral mais par les mains
et donc en réalité les mâts seront
partie des gestes barrières tout autant
que les solutés hydro alcooliques et
surtout la distanciation physique et le
fait qu'on ne touche pas les mêmes
objets voilà ce que je regrette
je objectivement je ne sais pas quelle
aurait été ma réaction
sur cette information je ne savais je ne
veux pas refaire l'histoire a posteriori
voilà donc pour l'audition d'agnès buzyn
ses derniers mots
je ne vais pas refaire l'histoire a
posteriori l'ancien ministre de la santé
a martelé qu'elle a anticipé la
situation
cette audition et toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à revivre tout
l'été sur lcp et sur notre site internet
lcp point fr